let me ask you this do you have uh
memorabilia from the first movie
when you're working on a set as cool as
the ones in the jurassic world franchise
it can be extremely tempting to sneak a
few bits from the set we're talking
everything from costumes to props to
shoes we've got a list of all the
memorabilia that the jurassic world
actors have snuck away from set with i
have this big secret i finally get to
share with the world number one
you never know when you'll need to train
a raptor
so chris pratt figured he'd be proactive
and take advantage of all the dino
training gear he could get his hands on
this included stealing the raptor
clicker trainer blue
blue
watch it to be fair it is pretty epic
we'd want to keep a prop that holds the
memories of working up close and
personal with those dinos too
even if they were animatronics in
reality
it's it's so good i'm so happy with it
yeah it is so awesome number two it
seems like this one was meant to be
alan grant gave this to me
25 years 25 years ago
and while it was gifted to her character
it certainly wasn't gifted to the
actress so she took matters into her own
hands
and laura dern stole it from jurassic
park the stunning amber ring she wore
all those years ago in the original
jurassic park films didn't leave her
finger when she said farewell to the
film and can we blame her
number three a good pair of boots is
hard to find
i found the original boots i kicked the
dinosaurs with those things and boots
that can survive battling dinos well you
can't let go of something as special as
that sam neil walked right off set with
his boots and never looked back that is
until he went back to the jurassic world
but we think he was pretty justified i
liked the boots yeah they were
comfortable i kept the boots and i found
them the other day number four
neil was on to something stealing those
boots chris pratt wound up following
suit for jurassic world dominion the
actor didn't want to leave the set
without his boots so he kept them and
hasn't even tried to cover it up too
much fully confessing online that he
swiped many items we're just getting
started it was unlike anything i've ever
done before it was so great number five
who doesn't love a tooth fairy
we knew him as star-lord and guardians
of the galaxy but in this franchise we
could refer to him as the protector of
dino teeth now if we were filming around
a bunch of prop dinosaurs there's no way
we wouldn't try to bring home some part
of a dino chris pratt is the lucky owner
of one of the many raptor teeth from set
but the way it came into his possession
well we're sensing a common theme here
the key is to figure out how to use it
number six
clothes that fit are pretty hard to let
go of who wants to say farewell to a
cool and comfortable pair of pants who
no one so why would chris pratt have
done anything but steal his jurassic
pants they were practical and
comfortable enough to work for hours at
a time on set
those are some quality pants
number seven
why leave a set with one piece of
clothing it seems like that might have
been chris pratt's goal in this case
since he finished his fully stolen
outfit off with this oh so cool vest no
doubt there are a lot of memories
associated with it and it looks
comfortable enough sleek and
leather-like but it doesn't seem like a
particularly special item that would
make an actor go out of their way to
steal it that said the pant vest and
boot combo is pretty on point
there you go and i just walked out
number eight we can't blame him for
wanting to swipe this one how many
people in the world get to have an
island id to call their own okay well
anyone who purchased the memorabilia
ones made but why do that when you've
got vip access to one pratt will always
be able to get where he needs to with
that badge in tow and we can't imagine
he wouldn't want to visit jurassic world
again so every time it's so nice so nice
number nine stealing small props is one
thing but weapons that's a whole other
deal this could seem kinda sketchy but
chris pratt didn't care one bit yes the
owen brady actor is the proud owner of
one of the knives that he used on set
well as we saw in the movie a knife can
come in very handy we have no doubt he
whips that one out regularly that's not
funny
a little funny
number ten yeah like the dino
okay so these props weren't stolen but
they were maybe the most epic gift given
to actors from set ever so we had to
mention it when jurassic park finished
filming steven spielberg gifted the lead
actors a real velociraptor animatronic
laura dern adores hers but it did have
to hide away for a few years after the
dino really freaked out her young child
but not to worry it's back out on
display now as it should be it was
really fun to work opposite the
dinosaurs in this movie we had
incredible animatronics if we were
working on a movie this cool we have no
doubt we would have left this set with a
few of these items as well did the prop
that you would have stolen wind up on
our list which other props are
swipeworthy if we could pull it off we
wouldn't say no to stealing a dino who's
in